[Music]
hello everyone good morning my name is
Donna I'm a software engineer on the
Basel team at Google in New York today
we are going to talk about problems that
certain organizations start to encounter
as their company and their projects grow
in particular with in relation to build
and test times and then go over the ways
in which the build tool basel can help
alleviate some of those pains and finish
up with a testimonial from the angular
team about how it's been working for
them so why might an organization need
basel certain problems start to arise as
your organization grows the your project
start to grow and the needs of your
infrastructure start to suffer with the
load that it requires and in turn this
might affect your the development
experience of the people at your
organization and in part this happens
because as you have more developers they
start to make more changes and more
changes means that you need to run all
of your tests far more often so if you
wanted to run all of your tests before
every submit that starts to increase as
you have more people the second thing
that affects this is as the feature
space starts to grow this obviously
increases just the sheer number of tests
that need to run so this is more load
that must happen with every change and
the final part is as your project
becomes larger each individual
integration test requires a ton of
computer just for a single one and so it
starts to become very quickly infeasible
to run all of your tests on every submit
so basically many organizations tend to
give up one integration testing and this
means that instead they'll break up
their projects into a number of micro
services where each service is
responsible for its own set of tests and
then those will run on every submit and
you'll only ever run your substantial
integration tests when you attempt to
release
so this is an example of a way that you
might break up some project and what
this means is that when you're releasing
that's the first time that you're going
to encounter problems with the
interaction between these different
micro services that have been working
separately all right so what is Basel
and how is it going to help this problem
and enable and empower your organization
to run all of these tests as often as
possible on Eve on every commit so basel
is a free and open-source automated
build and test tool this tool has been
used at google for nearly the past 15
years to build all of its source code
and i'm going to go over the properties
of basel that enable this that enable
you to run all of your tests across your
entire organization as often as you like
so the first property is that basil is
hermetic this means that basil is aware
of all inputs before the build begins so
of course this includes all of your
source files and everything that would
need to be built but this also includes
any tool for example that would need to
be used over the course of the build and
in turn this hermiticity directly lends
itself to basil being incremental and so
because basil is aware of all inputs for
any change you make basil can very
easily calculate the minimal amount of
work that needs to be done in order to
create your finished build product and
so if you make a small change you should
expect that the amount of work that
basil will do will be proportional that
it will be small so I'm going to
demonstrate that
all right so here's an example we're
starting we're asking basil to build all
the tests and just to start we see that
everything is fully cached so this is
imagining a scenario that you just did a
build right we're starting everything
was already built and now we're going to
make just a small change so the change
is going to be to a single test file so
a test a test itself often nothing
depends on that test so the expectation
is that when you make the change to this
single test that only that single test
will have to be rebuilt and retested so
here's an example test file we're going
to add a an additional assertion to this
test to make sure that everything or
that this thing is not no and then again
what we're going to do is we're going to
ask basil to retest everything but the
expectation is that basil will be
smarter and it will only rebuild that
single test and rerun that single test
so basil is working and beautiful
everything is cached but we see it
executed one out of 174 tests so that's
the one test that we edited everything
else is still cached all right
thank you all right the next property of
Basel is that it's deterministic so
Basel uses the checksum of all of the
inputs to the build in order to
determine whether or not they've changed
and what this means then is that basel
can very safely cache any intermediary
built build artifacts that it produces
and then instead of redoing the work to
do it if it if it knows that none of the
inputs have changed you can safely
retrieve the output artifact from this
cache and this is a huge opportunity for
optimization at your organization
because you're not bound to keep this
cache local you can share this crop this
cache across your entire organization
and all of your developers can populate
this cache and not only your developers
but your CI system can also populate
this cache and then whenever your
developers are doing builds basil can
then check the cache and see if the
artifacts that it needs are already
present and if yes simply retrieve them
without doing any work at all so this is
some example of how this cache might be
shared and of course what this means is
that for example the first build of the
day will also be fast if you say have
your cache and it's sorry if you have
your CI system populating this cache
then when your developers get to work in
the morning they do their first build
that build will probably be trivially
fast because almost all artifacts will
be cached very similar to the example
above before I change the test all right
and this cache can be anywhere so you
can use Google hub Google Cloud storage
in order to have this cache be in the
cloud not hosted by you but you can also
set up this cache to be hosted on
premises for everyone to use
okay and the final property of Basel
that we're gonna go over is that it's
fully cloud ready and so because of all
the previous properties that we talked
about it's hermeticity and it's
determinism not only can you store each
of the intermediary artifacts but you
can also do the work on the cloud all of
the built actions can happen in the
clouds so we're gonna look at an example
of another build so in this example in
this example as before we're imagining
we're starting from a clean slate
everything has been patched but this
time instead of changing a test file
this is editing a source file that is at
the very bottom of the project nearly
everything in this project depends on
this source file and so now you're going
to expect a full cache miss you're
making a unique change to your project
and so there's no way that the any
artifacts will be in the cache and so
basil will do its incremental build but
the incremental build still is a lot of
work and so it's going to start working
but now you're bound by the local
compute power that you have so we're
actually going to let this keep running
in the meantime
but as we said these builds can be moved
to the cloud so that you're no longer
going to be bound by the compute
resources that you have so to
demonstrate that we have this project
and similarly as before we're going to
start from a clean fully cached slate
and then we're going to make the same
edit to the same file that we did before
and again this is a file that everything
depends on so basil will have to do all
of the work to rebuild all of the
project and rerun all of the tests but
then when we invoke basil in a moment
we're going to see that we're going to
pass an additional flag that tells basil
to execute all of the build actions
remotely so this is setup that has been
done on this project there's a bit of
configuration and then you pass this
additional that doesn't work another - -
config equals remote flag and then basil
knows to run these actions remotely and
if we see here we can see that a hundred
and fifty actions are running
simultaneously so this project was
configured with a hundred and fifty
remote workers and basil is utilizing
all of it and this means that it's
running as many tests as the
configuration allows for so now what
happens is now that we see that the
number of actions running simultaneously
is dropping that's simply because there
aren't any more tests left to run and so
at this point you're simply bounded by
your slowest running test so let's just
go back at this point one hundred forty
two tests have been executed so far we
go back to the job that was running
locally we see that only 20 tests have
been executed and the times that we've
been working
yeah a couple of these tests take a
while to run so we will move on but we
see 100 154 have finished so far and
they're all concerning simultaneously so
14 are still running alright so that was
a demonstration of how basal will run in
the cloud and now I'm going to pass it
on to Alex to talk about angular and how
they've been using it thanks Donna hi
everybody my name is Alex eagle I work
on the angular team at Google I'm the
lead for our tooling team which includes
things like making the tools that our
angular users about one and a half
million of them used to develop their
applications as well as supporting our
own team and our internal development
velocity and I'm gonna tell you about
how much basil has improved our lives if
you haven't heard of angular it's a
enterprise scale web framework for
building very modern web applications
and it is a big project so how big is it
so as Donna pointed out the development
velocity on your project it depends on
how many people and how big the tests
are and you might think that you might
would need to break up your project so
you don't run all the tests all the time
that's really not what we wanted to do
so we wanted to use basil so that we
could run all of our tests all the time
and keep our development velocity high
and our numbers I just grabbed these off
of github and in the last 30 days we've
had 92 authors over 400 commits touching
over a thousand files so this is I would
say a pretty medium scale I know a lot
of enterprises have much bigger apps
than this but it is enough of a scale
that we saw the problem the basil solves
so this is what our continuous
integration time looks like you can
imagine a developer on the angular team
one of those 95 people having to wait an
hour for all of the tests to run and
then they find out something was broken
and so you can imagine going through
this round-trip many times this
significantly hurt our development
velocity and I want to point out here
that the numbers I'm showing here are
non incremental so this is just like the
uncashed
that's sort of the detail of the fact
that we get contributions from the open
source community and so using our own
cash has some security risks for us and
so this graph is showing that 60 minutes
is before we enabled the remote build
execution the dash dash config equals
remote sadhana showed and today I just
checked this morning and a typical
round-trip time is seven and a half
minutes to run all of the tests so this
is a decrease of 87% on our test time
and it has made a really big difference
to the angular team there are other
features of basil that that have helped
us out a lot
this is this is you know he's easily
worth the investment that we put into
migrating our build to basil so this
talk is about developing like Google and
the angular project itself is just a
small part of all of the angular work
that goes on at Google we have a lot of
customers internally over 600 of them
and some of these applications you've
probably used and all of these
applications rely heavily on remote
build execution to allow a very large
number of Google developers to be
productive working in these applications
and yes we write full stack integration
tests and expect them to run all the
time so now that angular itself has been
successfully ported to basil we want to
make it possible for all of you if
you're using angular to do the same
thing and so as we're developing an
opt-in preview which will ship in the
next month as part of version 8 of
angular that will allow all of our
enterprise users to be able to opt into
using basil we would plan to work with
them over the next six months to help
them find patterns of porting parts of
their build to run under basil and
allowed them to use remote build
execution and I also want to point out
that our plan for version eight is that
if you if you don't have a very
large-scale project there's actually no
porting required basil can just drop in
to your project it's really for for the
enterprise use cases that some extra
migration work will be needed so there's
one more thing I want to talk about we
showed how build and test can benefit a
lot from incrementality and can be run
by basil but we're at the cloud
conference and we are all thinking about
deploying services
let's talk about deployment for a minute
a year and a half ago when the angular
team switched to basil we we also
switched how we do our own deployments
and so we run basically a loop over our
packages of just doing basil deploy of
each one that's not that interesting
because we're a library and so our
deployment is a shipping an artifact to
a registry what's more interesting is
that we have an example application that
looks like an enterprise angular app
would and as Donna showed only the
change packages get rebuilt when we do a
deploy so basil smart enough to know
what work it needs to do but then the
changes that are produced by that can go
into a new layer in the docker image and
then only that new layer needs to be
uploaded at the container registry
because of course docker has the
property that each layer has the
checksum and if the check stubs match it
doesn't need to do any work
so the incrementality benefits can go
all the way from your build through to
your deployment and so I have a quick
video showing that
so this is this is our example
application and you see there's some
text there the live edit and deploy and
so we're gonna make a change to that
text I should point out while this is
running that all the demos you've seen
today we're actually angular itself and
so the 174 tests on it was running was
the angular repository that was a demo
of our actual day-to-day development
experience so now we're gonna run deploy
replace so the deploy target is a
kubernetes target this is going to go to
kubernetes engine and the replace is
just a verb saying what we want to do if
we were making a new application we
would say create and so basil as you can
see 13,000 actions didn't need to be run
so we got a lot of cash at benefits now
and then the remaining part the work
that's still happening here is we're
bundling up the application we're
running some slow steps to do the
production optimizations for this
application and it is a medium scale app
so that takes some time and then once
the app is fully built basil knows how
to construct the the docker image for it
and so now we see this image layer is
running it's running too quickly for me
to talk over just good and then a gzip
happened and so now there's a coop
cuddle command running this is the
command-line utility that deploys to
kubernetes so again I did all of this
with one command and I didn't need to
say what needed to be built first I just
said just like redeploy me I don't know
what changed so now we're gonna wait for
kubernetes engine to spin up some new
workers with the new code does a load
balancer in front and so now that live
edit shows up in the application so
that's all we have we're happy to answer
some questions after the talk we'll be
over here in this area thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]